all right a man's dating two women he
lies to one and is truthful to the other
which relationship does he value more
the one he lies to really yeah
uh I think if he's really valuing that
relationship he's trying to keep it
secure and like trying to make sure he
does everything within his realm to to
save that relationship and I think
somebody who's more open with he doesn't
really care about as much maybe I've
never thought about it that way yeah you
lie to keep it and you tell the truth
because you don't give a damn yeah yeah
but can't you also tell the truth
because you and that person have like
like yeah yeah a great relationship that
you're like hey it depends on what I'm
telling the truth about
it's about the other relationship right
is that what what you were getting at
just saying
the point is as he
he I'm sorry is he does he lie to her I
think that's the point it's not the two
yeah yeah I love you if I like his you
know otherwise I mean why not
but it's interesting I feel like men are
more straightforward than women though
as you should be yeah
what do you think do you lie to your
wife or tell her the truth
[Applause]
it's actually a really good I've never
thought about that I honestly don't know
like if she said she says do I look fat
in this dress and she does you telling
her I do
but but but so but my thing is I want it
to be better so so let me give you like
some real truth I've got people in my
family that passed away because of of
weight yeah so that to me as I'm serious
about that so I would absolutely be
honest of course in a kind way but
absolutely be honest what if she said
okay I saw you flirting with her were
you flirting with that girl and you were
you telling her the truth 100 denied
she talked to me
what about you
um
a man okay okay let me read it um a man
is dating two women he lies to one and
is truthful to the other which
relationship does he value more I'm
gonna say that it's one of those things
that's situational okay
um I think that you have some instance
where you may
want to protect somebody that you love
as you said
um and then there's other reasons where
you probably don't care so but
ultimately I think the truth is where it
should be across the board but I but I
think somebody would have somebody that
lies all the time will have to grow and
understand like the power of what truth
does but that has been situations where
uh men and women have lied because
they may not want to hurt the other
person but they may want to try to keep
the other person so what about the
situation girls you were flirting with a
girl she says
um did I see you flirting with that girl
at the store what's she saying
now I can save this it was harmless
because I mean men and women flirt all
the time
um and I think that we're moving into
the direction where people just be up
front I mean it's I mean they want me to
go to the movies and
um I don't know what some of the man you
guys seen over in the movies and you
sliding down you see like oh you just
helping okay that's for you
I mean that's considered like a flirt
right but it's it's not in person but
you guys are lusting over someone so I
just think it's just the nature of uh
men and women just imagine if you can
control it would you guys rather be have
someone be honest with you or lie to you
honest honest yeah I want somebody
that's honest with me I want both of us
to like grow you don't want someone to
be honest
[Laughter]
grow from the truth and tell me but if
it's gonna like especially if it's
something harmless lied to me because
then I'm gonna be stuck on it and then
now I'm gonna be insecure about it and
you can never go back to that grocery
store yeah because what if he says yeah
she was bad as hell
I'd rather just like not
no you but you'd rather he'd be like
straight up with that yeah I just I want
us to both grow like you were saying
that you do in your relationship I want
somebody to be honest with me if I have
a booger in my nose if I look crazy like
I want I want my uh partner to tell me
to you know go and change and stuff like
that
yeah I don't know I just think like
there's some things as a girl like we
don't really want to know
do you know an example
the flirting yeah you know and I I think
like I I think a lot of times like we
think we can handle the truth but then
we get it and we get mad or we get
insecure like we'll think about it for a
week when you know like one time like my
ex-boyfriend he he looked at me and he's
just like you are annoying the [ __ ] out
of me right now because I like I was
trying to talk to him when he got home
or whatever and I remember being like Oh
my God and I was thinking and I I
probably should have you know just let
him like because guys want to chill when
they get home they don't want to like
talk to you yeah but it's still like did
I do you really want that brutal honesty
on a regular basis what was it the way
he said it or just the fact that he said
it Ah that's probably the way he said it
but
I'm just thinking like if guys really
did had no filter and just said
everything they wanted to say I feel
like I would get my feelings hurt I mean
I think that uh again I've learned a lot
especially within the past uh like a
couple years just being in certain
situations that
the truth is the way to go you know and
um
if you're in a relationship I think you
should have open communication and men
should be able to set the foundations of
voice what it is that that they wanted
what they like because how else is she
gonna know to improve if he's not saying
anything you know I mean I don't
disagree it's just like I I feel like if
guys gave us unfiltered honesty I just
don't think most of us could take it but
actually want it I think that's where
the problem is yeah so men want to be
honest but a lot of women just can't you
can't handle it yeah a lot of women just
can't take it right yeah but if you've
dated before I'm sure you've heard baby
tell me the truth I won't get mad you're
like oh no you take me you said you
won't get mad and as soon as I kill you
right so so it's not just us being able
to talk like because we need to we want
yeah but can a woman hear us and receive
it without making it worse yeah more
than what it is and it's like I want to
be like yeah I can take it but I'm just
like being honest I'm like nah I don't
think I want to know every single like I
think there's some things I'd just
rather be like lied to about and it
depends on the situation because if I'm
getting fat tell me I'm
but if it's like you're flirting with a
girl don't tell me that I don't want to
know that do you guys want to know if he
cheats just one time you want to know no
no would you rather just like live in
okay hide it what if he has a side chick
you want to know
yeah I want it in the relationship
immediately
I'm calling cap on all these beautiful
women they the only way that they
wouldn't care is if they if it's heart
problem and then he's way ahead of him
if it's 50 50 they want to know about it
and this dude is going to hear he's
gonna hear for the rest of the
relationship
ladies I'm a lion
that's if she doesn't leave yep
you would say no I would leave oh you
would leave but if I don't know I won't
I just don't want to know then because
if I don't find out if you're gonna [ __ ]
is cheating does cheating hurt you if
you never find out yeah exactly but I
think he'll continue to do it
you never found out
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible